[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en Primera Plana un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
el activismo radical tras los sonados
casos en museos que se han acontecido en
las últimas semanas y que intentan
llamar la atención sobre la emergencia
climática para ello nos acompañan en
este estudio kantuta Quirós historiadora
del arte curador y docente bienvenida
cantuta Muchas gracias Patricia Cuba
schiller es abogada ambientalista y
responsable de la comisión América
Latina del colegio de abogados de París
bienvenida Patricia Muchas gracias y en
duplex también nos acompaña eugenicle es
doctorante en la escuela de altos
estudios en ciencias sociales de París
especializada en movilizaciones
ambientales bienvenida
Hola buenos días Muchas gracias por
tenerme aquí es un placer poder hablar
con ustedes hoy sobre militantísimo
ecológico entre Barcelona pues ahí vamos
activismo radical hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
en las últimas semanas activistas
medioambientales han multiplicado
acciones contra obras de arte para
alertar a la opinión pública sobre el
cambio climático entre las víctimas de
los ataques hay dos obras de Goya en el
Museo del Prado de Madrid los girasoles
de Van Gogh en Londres y una pintura de
Claude monet en Alemania entre otros la
lista es larga la última de la serie ha
sido una obra de Andy warhol en Milán
sobre la que cuatro activistas del grupo
llamado Última Generación lanzaron 8
kilos de harina el momento de urgencia
climática justifica estas llamadas de
atención Es efectivo o más bien Es todo
lo contrario es contraproductivo este
tipo de activismo de ello vamos a hablar
porque todo ello sucede cuando acaba de
concluir la con 27 en Egipto con
resultados bastante limitados repasemos
lo que dice la prensa el periódico de
Cataluña la Cumbre del clima concluye
sin avances para recortar emisiones la
revista primatch dedica esta portada a
los llamados ecologistas Ultra los
califica como generación del puñetazo
por sus acciones niveles el diario
Liberación cop27 la urgencia esperará
acuerdo de mínimos para un fondo para
países vulnerables pero poco más ante la
gravedad de la situación planetaria y el
coogue haga internacional dedica esta
portada a esa juventud que se adhiere a
la preocupación climática con
manifestaciones de todo tipo Bueno yo
creo que este de hoy es un asunto sobre
el que todos nos hemos formado una
opinión Todos hemos debatido en nuestras
casas en bares todos tenemos es el
debate de moda vista la urgencia
planetaria teniendo en cuenta los datos
Porque es verdad que los datos son
científicos los datos están ahí la
radicalidad está justificada sí o no
cantuta Bueno a mí me cuesta un poco la
palabra radicalidad que me parece más
que se trata de espectacular un
activismo espectacular que se inscribe
en una historia muy larga de la
yesobediencia civil y más bien me parece
que estos militantes se inscriben en una
ética de catástrofe de tiempo
catastróficos y que escogen medios con
mayor efecto mediático y efecto
espectacular más bien como
sintiéndose responsable hacia la
historia Entonces es una una
responsabilidad histórica hasta hacia el
presente pero también hacia el futuro y
entonces
eso lo la medida de la de la de la
eficiencia
creo que puede ser medidas sobre todo en
un tiempo largo solamente en los efectos
ahora en la Esfera mediática pero
también en un largo más largo plazo lo
vamos a hablar de eso de esa medida de
eficiencia porque me parece un concepto
muy interesante que hay que tener en
cuenta a la hora de valorar este
activismo Patricia estos actos están
justificados la emergencia climática
Mira yo te diría que tú mismo acabas de
hacer un poco el contexto en el que
estamos viviendo El día de hoy estos
actos efectivamente yo coincido con
cantuta sobre el tema radical también me
molesta un poco porque al final de
cuentas es una manifestación de una
terrible frustración de la juventud que
ante la prueba científica que tu citas
el sexto informe de los científicos del
yec Ok todo está clarísimo que tenemos
que tomar acciones las los resultados
tan pobres de la co-27
y y bueno eso se sigue año tras año
entonces
efectivamente creo que
antes
hay que hay que contextualizar Y eso es
lo que explica esta necesidad de llamada
de atención de focalizar un poco con
temas o reacciones un poco shock la
atención pública y movilizar y
sensibilizar a
aquellos los que finalmente tienen en
sus manos hacer algo eficaz
efectivo y yo diría ahí sí radical de
cambio Es verdad que el lenguaje lo
semántico en este tema cuenta mucho
luego vamos a hablar de que les parece
la palabra eco terrorismo que también se
está utilizando mucho estos días y bueno
radical se puede interpretar tampoco
como algo peyorativo la radicalidad
llegado el punto puede ser bueno Y puede
ser necesaria para pero lo vamos a
hablar luego vamos en este punto con
eugenicleman doctorante en la escuela de
altos estudios sociales de París
especializada en movimiento en
movilizaciones ambientales señora crema
cómo ha ido evolucionando el activismo
medioambiental en los últimos años se ha
ido radicalizando por llamarlo así a
medida que la situación del planeta se
iba haciendo cada vez más insostenible y
la evidencia científica así lo iba
confirmando
bueno el cambio climático es un fenómeno
global pero las respuestas siempre
también son culturales y se adaptan o
sea tienen que ver con las culturas
también locales entonces por eso también
vemos una multitud de respuesta que
pueden ser diferentes entre en los sures
globales en el norte en el occidente o
en territorios indígenas
entonces más que nada Y si nos
interesamos se ha ido realizando en qué
sentido se ha radicalizado
Más bien yo diría que
se ha radicalizado las respuestas de las
autoridades
ha pasado de ser en occidente digamos
unas luchas neuronamentales más bien
individualistas como cambiar su consumo
o ser como más consciente al nivel de
los grasos etcétera A una crítica más
política y más centrada en una crítica
del capitalismo y del colonialismo y de
cómo sus efectos se sienten en el
territorio y en las relaciones entre
humanos y no humanos
muy interesante vamos a centrarnos sobre
todo Aprovechando que tenemos a kantuta
para hablar desde el arte como elemento
Por qué los activistas climaticos Esto
se lo preguntan mucha gente han elegido
el mundo del arte que intentan Mostrar
con ese impacto hacia el arte
precisamente cantuta no solamente
escogen el mundo del arte porque esto
estos militantes también hacen acciones
en puentes en
lugares más
estructurales logísticamente
estamos viendo que lo que tiene impacto
realmente es cuando vemos esa esos
girasoles esas obras muy conocidas eso
es lo que realmente tiene el impacto si
quizás si solo hicieran acciones en
puentes Nos estarán de acuerdo conmigo
no estaríamos hablando de esto de aquí
yo creo que hay una una un método un
método que está eligiendo que es el
método de la metonomía O del cine hablar
de la parte para hablar del todo
entonces vemos que los cuadros que han
elegido por ejemplo el de los de Van
Gogh o otros son pinturas de paisaje y
entonces hay una metonomía muy clara Tal
vez un poco literal entre el cuidado que
tenemos hacia las obras de arte y el
cuidado que tendríamos que tener hacia
la tierra Entonces yo creo que hay Esa
esa relación de equivalencia que están
destacando y
al mismo tiempo creo que eligen también
el museo como un escenario que así
teatral y en esto se ponen a la a la
entrecrucimiento entre dos genealogías
creo de manera de concebir el museo el
museo como templo que es una manera muy
histórica de pensar el museo como el que
protege las obras de hace y al mismo
tiempo el museo como como foro
y como un lugar donde se construye la
Esfera pública y también donde se
construye la ciudadanía y entonces yo
creo que juega con estos dos
maneras de ver el museo y
es me parece bastante hábil como como
manera de
resignificar este espacio muy importante
para para nosotros la radicalidad no sé
si puede estar justificada pero la
acción puede ser contraproducente el
activismo tiene Patricia que tener en
cuenta por regla tener la seguridad que
una acción va a ser efectiva para su
causa o Esto no es así
esa relación
te entiendo creo que y solamente para
completar un poco también el tema que
planteabas hace un momento
definitivamente el arte o es este tipo
de obras de arte es algo que casi tiene
un consenso global o sea cubre un poco
lo que decías hace un momento no tiene
el mismo efecto
atacar o este tipo de símbolos que
son consensuales casi todas las
latitudes son admirativas del arte de
estas obras Entonces vas a llegar a un
público mucho más amplio y sobre la
pregunta precisa que que planteas la
eficacidad En qué medida Esto va a tener
o por qué en qué medida tienen que ser
necesariamente eficaces yo diría de que
yo no estoy convencida de que no sean
eficaces al contrario pienso que hay dos
fases la primera es una reacción de
rechazo primas el primero es un choque
porque es la imagen dice Wow
por supuesto esta gente y efectivamente
Ahí vas a tener una primera reacción
quizá de aversión y luego
lo que yo creo que estas estos jóvenes
desean es que finalmente la persona va a
interesarse un poco en comprender pero
Cómo llegan a esta situación y eso hay
como un espacio te das cuenta creo que
hay dos fases o es progresivo y la
eficacia se puede dar desde el momento
en que tú llegas a un cierto número de
personas que van a finalmente
quizá interesarse más y en ese sentido
pienso que tienen un efecto positivo
evidentemente si las hacemos lo que
queremos es que sean que que lograr
llegar al a la gran cantidad de gente y
yo creo que lo han logrado porque ha
suscitado mucho interés muy interesante
voy a hacer una breve pausa para la
vuelta les quiero preguntar por el
concepto eco terrorismo que tanto
estamos utilizando estos días y también
les voy a preguntar si hay otras causas
a lo largo de la historia que
han estado asociadas a este tipo de
activismo va a ser a vuelta de pausa
aquí en Primera Plana hasta ahora
[Música]
France 24 es más que nunca una ventana
abierta al mundo
[Música]
libertad
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando si me lo permite en el término
de activismo radical a partir de las
acciones en museos contra cuadros de
activistas pop medioambientalistas de
las últimas semanas bueno pongo en tela
de juicio la palabra radical porque ya
hemos hablado de que la semántica en
este debate es bastante complicada y nos
acompaña en kantuta Quirós historiadora
del arte Patricia Cuba schiller abogada
ambientalista y en duplex eugeni
clemanes doctorante en la escuela de
altos estudios en ciencias sociales de
París vamos a hablar del lenguaje eco
terrorismo es la palabra de la polémica
la noción no existe en derecho
entendemos le preguntado a Patricia que
es un tipo de lenguaje creado cuando
consideran que debe usarse si es que
consideran que se debe de usarse para
este tipo de acciones Patricia
no definitivamente Es un término que
desde ya es inapropiado porque estamos
combinando dos acciones que no tienen
realmente nada que ver entre una es
la
una vez más la frustración la necesidad
de enfocar la enfocar la atención sobre
esta problemática ambiental esta crisis
ambiental y bueno el terrorismo es
sabemos perfectamente a lo que puede
llegar es inapropiado como tú bien dices
no es un término jurídico Es un término
que que se usa pero yo Considero que es
un término extremadamente peligroso
peligroso porque
al final
puede llegar a
asociar esta este tipo de acciones en
perjuicio de Los Defensores de del
ambiente
hace un momento oíamos efectivamente que
las manifestaciones se varían en función
de las latitudes
yo puedo hablar por América Latina
efectivamente en la zona América Latina
no olvidemos hay bastantes problemáticas
y sobre todo pues las garantías de los
derechos y la integridad física de estos
Defensores del ambiente quizá tengan
acciones menos radicales pero
precisamente apoyan con su acción y usar
el término de eco terrorismo podría
legitimar acciones de represión mucho
más severas mucho más fuertes y creo que
en ese sentido es efectivamente
peligroso utilizarla me imagino pequeño
apunte los museos tienen sistemas de
seguridad muy afinados contra este tipo
de actos imagino que protocolos incluso
algunas instituciones algunos museos muy
importantes han hablado que preferían en
estos casos tener un perfil bajo para
evitar lo que llaman un efecto llamada
de este tipo de acciones
Sí pero más recientemente hubo la
declaración de lifecom que es una
reunión de los museos internacionales ya
están cambiando un poco de de discurso
no no no condenan ahora totalmente
las acciones y yo creo que tal vez los
museos que ya están cumpliendo un giro
también ecológico sobre los
hemos hablado en otras ocasiones de las
instituciones museísticas como deben
seguir la sensibilidades de la sociedad
como era importante ellas están
bifurcando también en sí misma con los
los la imprenta ecológica Y entonces Tal
vez eso va también un poco
variar también con el tiempo largo
el elemento diferenciador en este caso
es que la obra está protegida es decir
que al final la sangre no llega al río
para que se me entienda
que sí que lo pudiera hacer es decir que
se la obra de arte llegar hasta llegar a
destruirse cambiaría la consideración
del acto en sí es decir ese es el límite
crear un verdadero daño les pregunto No
no quiero hacer abogado del
cantuta yo creo que ellos juegan sobre
ese límite es parte
el método simbólico que que ellos usan
juegan sobre ese límitente y también
sobre nuestra imaginación de la
destrucción y de la autodafe como algo
que es muy tabú en la historia porque lo
conoces conocemos los los
destrucción de obras de arte y Qué
quiere decir entonces ellos juegan
precisamente sobre esta línea roja y me
parece que
a este juego con el borde es también un
juego como lo decía antes sobre el daño
que es que la amenaza del daño hacia la
tierra y hacia las obras no sé si me
entienden
porque nos gustaría que nos trazará el
un perfil del activista ecologista de
hoy en día lo solemos asociar con un
perfil joven de una generación con
estudios que se resiste a ver hipotecado
su futuro pero depende también de la
latitud imaginemos
bien si un poco nos centramos en lo que
pasa en Europa o en Estados Unidos
Bueno también en territorios indígenas
primero más que nada se caracterizan por
su juventud
la mayoría de esos
activistas son jóvenes
después cuando miramos su movilización
lo que fue lo más importante es también
el papel de la infancia y de lo que
llamamos la socialización primaria Y
cómo los contactos que tuvieron muy de
niños con la naturaleza o con un
territorio
sea por los abuelos que acaban
campesinos o por viajes pero una
relación muy fuerte desde pequeño que
los marcó que marcó a la niñez y que
desde ahí de ahí desencadenó una
necesidad de proteger a la naturaleza
y de defender los derechos de la
naturaleza y esto se encuentra tanto
cuando hablo con jóvenes indígenas en
Estados Unidos como con activistas en
Europa
les pregunto el hecho de saber que pocos
o Ninguno de los no convencidos con los
argumentos del cambio climático van a
convencerse mediante estos actos porque
es verdad que el que no está convencido
viendo este tipo de acciones no va a
convencerse esto no Debería ser y vuelvo
a hacer de abogado del una causa
fundamental para no perpetrar el acto
saber que no va a ser transformador la
acción del activista pregunto Patricio
yo me mantengo un poco en la posición de
lo que te comentaba hace un momento creo
que
yo no sería tan pesimista en el sentido
de que no van a crear necesariamente un
efecto
rechazo un rechazo a sobre todo que si
me permites Volver al tema precedente tú
hablabas En qué medida va a cambiar la
percepción
el hecho de que no haya un daño real
desde ya legalmente hablando sí es es Es
esencial porque
tú podrás
actuar contra estos jóvenes o estos
manifestantes por
atentado a la propia privada al museo
etcétera Pero no hay un daño material
que legalmente pueda ser
puesto en en evidencia porque
efectivamente las obras en sí mismas no
han sido afectadas
el rechazo social vendría a partir del
daño entendemos que ahora solo se
produce el shock con este tipo de
acciones
no este juego entre la frontera de de lo
que realmente no no van a pasar esa
línea Roja de realmente por dañar una
obra de arte pero el efecto es Wow es es
esto un poco lo que ellos buscan
sensibilizar y pasar un mensaje porque
en el momento mismo hay un mensaje hay
un eslogan hay una reivindicación hay
una protesta entonces
creo que
bueno desde mi punto de vista es es
interesante y es una vez más una
necesidad de hacer algo ante ante
acciones que que no no venía sobre la
generación de estos activistas no sé si
queréis señalar algo más aparte de lo
que había dicho la señora cleman
hablamos de esta de estos activistas
jóvenes que ven Su futuro hipotecado y
de ahí entienden este activismo no
cantuta Sí yo creo que es muy
interesante lo que está pasando porque
hay este tipo de activismo pero también
hay otro fenómeno en la misma generación
que es el de la deserción no sé si la
deserción de unos estudiantes en grandes
escuelas francesas que han pronunciado
discursos de diciendo que están
se están yendo de la manera de hacer por
ejemplo
agronomía o arquitectura como Lucero
hacia antes de manera muy importante y
entonces yo creo que hay como una huida
muy interesante que también es una
bifurcación y que son muchos puntos en
la juventud que se están entremezclando
y es una una manera de sentirse
responsable hacia la historia creo que
vamos con este punto con la señora
cleman porque usted Estudia me interesa
mucho que usted Estudia poblaciones
autóctonas y luchas ambientales algo que
contrasta mucho con la militancia de
estos grupos y las consecuencias que
enfrentan con la militancia considerada
como radical en Europa no esto también
ha ido cambiando bastante en los últimos
años yo empecé en
2015-2016 a trabajar con campesinos
autóctonos en la nación o sea entre
Arizona y Nuevo México y en aquel
entonces ellos sí que me tienen una
crítica acerca de los activistas
ecológicas blancos diciendo bueno ellos
hacen activismo pero para nosotros se
trata de sobrevivir
Entonces ellos pueden volver a su casa
pueden volver a su vida o tienen tiempo
y dinero para esta militancia pero para
nosotros se trata de nuestra vida en
nuestros territorios ahí también es muy
importante el papel de la crítica del
colonialismo y del capitalismo que
llevaron los pueblos indígenas en la
militancia ecológica y Entonces hubo una
respuesta muy fuerte también in
autocrítica de los activistas ecológicas
en Europa acerca de es cierto Tenemos
también que pensar en las raíces de esos
problemas de Dónde surge tal problema
Entonces también se lleva una lucha
diferente en Europa en Estados Unidos
para ir también a la raíz de esto y
también concientizar a la población
bueno con un poco lo que pasa no el
nivel de arte en los museos de
intervenciones
esto claramente este tipo de acción es
imposible en
América Latina por ejemplo los
protectores ambientales en América
Latina bueno en Colombia y en México son
los que más sufren por defender su
territorio y la respuesta del estado y
de los padres militares no es solo la
cárcel sino la muerte
Totalmente de acuerdo porque
efectivamente este tipo de
manifestaciones todas las vas a ver en
América Latina a pesar de que si te
pones a pensar somos
regiones que estamos directamente
impactadas de de plano con los efectos
del cambio climático
efectivamente lo que lo que se menciona
es un poco lo que yo yo decía hace un
momento el día de hoy tenemos países en
la región
en los cuales
hay asesinatos realmente de Defensores
ambientalistas
y yo creo que las acciones Al final
contribuyen a a
mejorar esta situación Pues ahí lo
dejamos Muchísimas gracias ha sido muy
interesante Patricia cantuta y a todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana quien en
Primera Plana Muchas gracias
[Música]